you do you want a relationship or not
with somebody not me definitely because
what you're saying makes no sense like
well what am I saying you're saying that
you want me to submit to you and you
want me to cook and clean for you but
also you want to masculate maybe let
your guard down a little bit become more
vulnerable
submissive things do you want a husband
that's going to cook and clean for you
cooking is not submissive cooking is
just it's a simple question yeah but
he's saying so are you saying that
cooking and cleaning is as a man is
submissive yes
crazy do you want a husband that cooks
and cleans for you why not okay